mysterious growing blades the most
powerful homeless man I've ever met and
the hammer battle that would make even
MC Hammer blush the rings of Power
episode 2 is here and along with it a
lot more lore background and theories to
discuss if you haven't checked out my
episode 1 video definitely do that then
come on back grab a pipe because we have
a lot to talk about the episode begins
where we last left Galadriel alone in
the great sea after abandoning her trip
to valinor faster than my trip to Mexico
when kovid started it's interesting that
she looks upward toward the light of the
constellation seeing that a big theme of
last episode was how do you know which
way is toward the light up or down
you'll notice there are a few Bright
Stars here pointing out a constellation
is she using this for navigation or is
this somehow linked to those strange
symbols will later see the stranger
carving into rock speaking of the
stranger Nori has stumbled upon his
location after he fell from the sky
while her friend Poppy isn't too keen on
the idea of helping him Nori sees no
other choice accidentally falling
through the smoldering ground around him
but finding out it's not hot at all our
first clue that this stranger could be
Sauron is the lack of heat from the
Flames if you recall in episode 1 when
Galadriel was in forward with she
remarked that the place was so evil
their torches gave off no warmth I
wonder if something similar is happening
here clue 2 are these levitating rocks
when he Rouses to Consciousness
galadural did refer to Sauron as a
sorcerer clue 3 is this blast of wind
similar to what happened to Theo when he
touched the Broken Sword which had the
mark of Sauron on it Nori and Poppy both
remark this person certainly cannot be a
man for he would have been squished upon
Landing nor does he look like an elf in
my episode 1 video I theorized that this
could be Gandalf and that the writers
are trying to make us think that it's
Sauron but at this moment there's only
really one clue that could point to it
being Gandalf and that's his ability to
talk to other creatures he'll talk to
these fireflies and it reminded me of
Gandalf whispering to a moth which led
him to being saved by an eagle from his
imprisonment at Isengard another Point
against it being Sauron is that he seems
to have no recollection of who he is
plus the Orcs have already started their
encroachment into the lands of men which
I would imagine requires a leader like
Sauron behind it so Nori and Poppy
decide to help this stranger with Nori
believing deep down that there must be a
reason she's supposed to find him she
also knows caring for him would be
frowned upon by the harfoot people who
prefer to keep to themselves and who are
incredibly superstitious if anything out
of the ordinary happens that's usually
who or what they'll blame if something
bad happens and I guarantee something
bad will happen I wonder if those wolves
will come back they tease them in
episode 1 but we haven't seen them since
wolves have also been known to be
attracted to Sauron so if they do come
for this stranger in the next episode or
so I will be talking about that across
the continent we find bronwyn's
ancestral home of Horton completely
destroyed but the strange thing is
there's no bodies the town has been torn
asunder by large Fishers in the ground
erandir goes to investigate but before
he does he almost kisses a Bronwyn it's
a forbidden kind of love in a region the
home of the noldor elves we find the
home of kellebrimbor the master
Craftsman who King gilgalad has sent on
a special Mission tasking elrond to help
him devise something of real power this
is likely a nod to the rings of power of
which the series is titled in order to
do this they'll need to build a tower
one which can host a forged stronger
than any other ever built and it needs
to be complete by Spring the only
problem they just don't have the
Manpower seriously The Elves and men
don't have a great relationship at this
point so asking them to help out is out
of the question luckily elrond has an
inn with the nearby dwarves of Casa Doom
him having a long time friendship with
Prince during the fourth perhaps The
Elves and dwarves can work together to
forge something that would benefit both
peoples something Keller brimbor said
could potentially transform all of
Middle Earth I also want to take a
moment to talk about feenor's Hammer
feenor was killer brimbor's grandfather
and King of the noldor one of his
greatest achievements was creating the
silmarells and this was done with this
Hammer these were three gems of immense
beauty within which burned the light of
valinor from the two trees of which we
saw in episode 1. it appears kelle
brimbor wants to do something that will
have people remember him just like his
grandfather so elrond and Caleb rimbor
set forth to the Dwarven stronghold of
kazadum which will see the fellowship
Venture through thousands of years in
the future but elrond isn't greeted with
a ceremonious blasting of Ram's horns as
he thought in fact he's turned away in
order to be granted an audience with the
prince he invokes the ancient right of
second a test of endurance in which two
competitors smash rocks until one can no
more this Ploy actually gets him inside
where he asked Keller brimbor to give
him a few days to sort things out inside
we see a markerly different Kaza Doom
than we do in the fellowship the place
is just teeming with life with large
waterfalls and the manipulation of the
sun through mirrors which allows for
them to grow their own crops Prince
Duran is not at all pleased to see his
supposed friend in fact if elrond loses
this competition he will be banned from
their land for good however if he wins
elrond will be granted a single Boon
which is just a fancy word for a favor
or request meanwhile Nori tries to
communicate with a stranger whose scream
can apparently blast wind he has no
recollection of who he is or how to eat
escargot for that matter the stranger's
arrival also coincides with Nori's
father breaking his foot something that
will hinder his ability when the group
is to migrate so if the heart our foots
find out Nori and Poppy have been
harboring this guy they'll surely be
blamed for anything ill that befalls
them we also see that the stranger has
written on the rocks and bark what could
potentially be constellations he came
from the sky Galadriel saw a
constellation from the sea and sadik
remarked that the sky looks strange as
he looked upwards Galadriel finds
herself saved by a group of humans whose
ship was destroyed by a sea creature
they call the worm At first she hides
her long ears knowing how elves are
perceived among men but when she's
discovered she's Saved by the Bell and
the ship is attacked galantriel and a
man by the name of Hal brand a character
created just for the show are the only
two survivors back at kazadum elrond
concedes to the prince he will be
banished but asks for one thing in
return that the prince escort him to the
exit it's here we find out why the
prince has such resentment for him 20
years have passed and not once did
elrond come to visit he didn't come to
his wedding or or come see him when his
children were born elrond really doesn't
have an excuse here other than the fact
he's an elf and perceives time
differently 20 years for an elf is but
the blink of an eye still he apologizes
with the hope that Duran will let him
apologize to his wife in person
something Duren agrees to here we meet
princess disa unlike Duran she is a
character created for the show and ends
up being the very reason elrond just
might pull off his plan and getting help
from the dwarves she plays a pivotal
role in getting Duran in elrond to
reconcile there's also mention of a seed
elrond gave Prince Duran a seed from the
great Tree in Linden it has now grown
big and strong I just hope it doesn't
start dropping those black Ghoulies we
saw in episode 1. how Brandt is hiding
something in his pouch here something he
does not disclose to Galadriel we aren't
exactly sure what this symbol represents
but Galadriel guesses it's the mark of
his King he tells her he was chased from
his homeland by Orcs And that it's
nothing but Ash now interestingly enough
he says he's from the Southlands the
same place erandir and Bronwyn found the
destroyed town of Horden does halbrand
have a connection to this town and it
definitely seems like he's hiding a lot
more from Galadriel at the tavern
Bronwyn tries to warn the town of what
happened in Horton but no one will
believe this crazy elf lover if she's
going to convince them to pack things up
and move she'll need proof and this
proof just so happens to be lying
underneath the floorboards of her house
a day ago Theo mentioned that mice
underneath the floorboards have been
driving him mad which is all a setup to
him thrashing the floor when he hears a
noise I bet his mom is gonna love coming
home to that there is however something
far more dangerous than a mouse beneath
the floorboard something that hasn't
been seen in years in orc these Orcs
seem to be using an expansive tunneling
system one which arondir discovers
underneath Horton he also finds these
claw marks along the side of the tunnel
with something that resemble assembles a
bladed figure I'm still a bit perplexed
on what exactly this is but if you think
you know let me know in the comments
Aaron deer finds himself chased in the
tunnels below and eventually captured
but don't count his character off for
dead remember that no bodies were found
in Horton so if it's assumed Air India
was captured by Orcs he will likely be
taken as a slave which is what likely
happened to the people of Horton when
Bronwyn arrives home after
unsuccessfully convincing the
townspeople that the Orcs are back guess
who manages to stumble into her home but
an actual orc and I gotta say Matt props
to Theo and Bronwyn here who instead of
pissing themselves in fear do some great
teamwork to fight and kill him now
Bronwyn finally has her proof to
convince the town as if things couldn't
get worse for halbern and Galadriel the
two are sucked into a massive storm
where Galadriel is wrapped up in rope
and flung overboard now halbrandt could
have let her sink but he risks his own
life and goes after her using
galadriel's own blade to cut her free
I've already started to see some
theories online that Hal brand is Sauron
but I'm not convinced if anything he may
become one of The Naz ghoul a man so
corrupted by a ring of power he turns
into a wraith and one of sauron's most
ruthless servants still it's a bit early
for any of that Nori and Poppy watches
the stranger communicates with the
fireflies it seems as though he's trying
to use them to point out a constellation
Nori says she's never seen those Stars
before but she has a good idea where to
find them maybe one of sadak's books can
offer Insight we get our first look at
king during the third the prince's
father and it seems the two are scheming
the prince assures the king that elrond
doesn't know but we aren't sure exactly
what they're talking about even though
the prince Tres elron the king reminds
him that there's no trust between hammer
and rock one day one must break so even
though it looks like the dwarves and
elves may be working together in the
future Something Fishy is definitely
going on in front of them is some sort
of chest we never get to see what's
inside it but the fact that it's laid
out on this Jeweler's table we know that
dwarves love riches and it glows my best
guess is this is some sort of Jewel or
treasure something that may have even
once belonged to the elves in one of the
more intriguing scenes of the episode
Theo's blood mysteriously coalesces with
the Black Blade and it magically
reforges itself there are currently two
theories on what this thing could be the
first and not that exciting at all is
that it's simply made for the show the
second and much cooler is that it's the
Legendary Blade girthang a blade
originally forged from a meteorite funny
we saw something that resembled the
meteorite fall to Earth in episode 1 but
no telling if these two are in any way
related the Blade's last owner was Turin
turembar one of the first ages biggest
hero and this blade was said to have a
will of its own it broke when Turin fell
upon the blade after he found out his
sister wife had killed herself The Shard
of the blade were buried with Turin
beneath the stone of the hapless which
is now the island of tall Morrowind so
if this blade is girthang it would have
had to have somehow made its way all the
way from this island to where Theo is in
the get to know the Southlands
featurette there's a great shot of the
map which indicates the Southlands is
located right where Mordor is so it's
totally possible that what we're
watching right now is the beginning of
sauron's takeover of this land whatever
this blade is I don't think it bodes
well for Theo it seems like it has
somehow bonded with him it could even be
leading the Orcs to him but anything
with the mark of Sauron on it can't be
good the final scene shows Galadriel and
halbrand rescued by a large ship now
I've seen the coming ahead this season
trailer so if you don't want to be
spoiled on where I think these two are
headed turn away now I'd place my money
that this is a new minorian ship they
are headed to numenor now we'll later
see how brand jailed here but it's
uncertain if this is for something he he
did in the past or something he'll do
when they get there a famous numenorian
you might know is Aragorn who descended
from the Duna Dane the word used to
describe descendants of numenoreans who
came to the mainland of Middle Earth so
that's where we're left at the end of
episode 2. what are your thoughts and
theories on the rings of power I want to
hear them in the comments below thanks
for watching everyone please make sure
to like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember
thank you
foreign